j paul good for boxing or is he bad for  boxing  answer for me  i'm i'm the best thing that's happened  to boxing in a century  period  you know and  the legends would agree and the anthony  joshua's the mike tysons the manny  pacquiao's the tyson fury's  they've all said what i'm doing for  boxing's a breath of fresh air i think  that debate you know  started  about a year ago is jake paul good for  boxing  i  i  have silenced that and i don't think  there's anybody on the other side of the  equation who thinks i'm bad for boxing i  think this sport  needed that  revival and that younger audience to  come in and  really reinvigorate it because it was  dying out it was boring and i brought a  new social media wave to it where now  fighters are copying everything i do on  social media to promote their fights